The speed that doesn't fall suddenly into top gear and the
dribbling with a big one strike is dangerous.The
distance you go with an action is huge and
you won't be able to make it in time after a huge reaction.Acceleration
This is the speed of the vibration Loki
This is the world selection
[Music]
OK sprinter
speed
I don't need any whining.  Bring it out, stop it, I'll hold it in
between the two of us The country's fast back is aiming between us. Is
this the target? I'll stop the aerial battle. There's a lot of
reservations.
Ario can't fly freely. It's
terrible.
But the green update arrives. I'm
overwhelmed.
Men.
Ours.  Weapons are now overwhelming in every way What we've been
doing at Blue Rock
now won't work There's something here that we can never match
The distance to the highest peak in the world
This is the level I want to reach
Soccer is amazing
I want to go there  There too